a lot of you said y'all wanted to get
rid of Zach Wilson yall shamed him he
got blamed by the media he got blamed by
everyone coach said that was their best
option at quarterback and you thought
anybody can just play quarterback in the
NFL cuz y'all just think quarterback is
just the easiest job which is not Zach
Wilson's execution hasn't been great but
in reality he's a good enough player to
win games everyone cares about what your
quarterback did and if he performed
enough and good enough to win and he's
in New York New York's huge inall New
York media and you guys deliberately
killed this man's confidence y
single-handed broke him down if I'm Zach
and you know this team may move on from
me you have this narrative that is
painted against you and you have an
opportunity to fix it that's a bey thing
about life and if I are you I don't care
what no one says I'mma go out here and
just play my brand of football and
that's the best thing you can do